caesar clown
is often named as one of the prime
candidates as a possible next straw hats
and while i believe that he in theory
fulfills the basic requirements for this
i think his character actually serves a
completely
different purpose in the story after all
there aren't all too many parallels to
draw between the lord of the rings
and one piece two of my all-time
favorite works of fiction one thing
however that both of these worlds
undoubtedly share
is their seeming disregard and even
distaste
for science and scientific advancement
in their epic world building
now while there clearly is some
scientific progress in both worlds
it tends to be associated with military
power destruction
and an overall threat to the vast beauty
and pureness of a world
where strength courage and will
determine one's success in battle
and where the heroes strive to forge a
path to peace
and freedom after all we don't want to
see a world
where aragon drives around in the
corvettes ordering drone strikes on
mordor
in the lord of the rings the best
example for
stark technological and industrial
progress is saruman
whose ambitious undertakings to wage war
go hand in hand with the destruction of
the environment
that in the end fights back against him
and bringing this all the way back to
one piece
the face of science and technical
advancement in one piece
is of course none other than dr vagapod
yes it's without any doubt the biggest
tragedy of caesar's character
that even as the archetypical mad
scientist type of antagonist
he's not the dominant face of science in
one piece
his arc is arguably the most
insignificant after the time skip
and his battle with the straw hats was
not exactly
what you call a close call and still
caesar has stuck around for
four consecutive arcs in the story going
from punk hazard
over dressrosa and zou all the way to
whole cake islands
traveling together with the crew and
developing his very own dynamic will
luffy and co
until he finally was free to go his own
way after the events of the wedding
it's no real wonder then that similar to
characters like momo of vv
caesar for the longest time was a top
contender
for the next spot on the sunny and while
i strongly believe
that caesar wouldn't be a great fit for
the crew at all
as we'll see over the course of this
video i also think that people who
straight out disregarded this
as an unrealistic option have overlooked
some crucial
aspects of his character because caesar
in fact fulfills a number of
general qualifications that are strongly
associated with being straw hats
having a quirk a dream and a tragic
backstory
and now if you're shaking your head at
this let me convince you otherwise
oh yeah and before we get into it if you
haven't subscribed the channel yet
make sure to hit that big red button
below this video
i think we don't have to say too much
about caesar being the sort of quirky
addition to the crew
that luffy loves to make
[Music]
his strange appearances his logia devil
fruit
as well as his socially awkward
personality undoubtedly would make him a
great fit among a talking skeleton
a pervy cyborg and a caddy-loving
reindeer
so i think we can definitely cross this
one off the list
what about the tragic backstory then
[Music]
here it might already be less obvious
for some people
however as we will explore in more
detail later on
caesar does indeed have a tragic
backstory
it's undeniable that he's actually a
quite intelligent and academically
capable person that has dedicated his
entire life
to science and research and yet despite
all that he's still outshone by vegapunk
for what is basically
his entire professional life there seems
to be nothing that he can surpass him in
and he suffers
heavily under this regard that people
have for him always in the shadow of
this
other brilliant scientist that is
creating technology
500 years ahead of the current age
given his psychopathic and apathetic
personality
that is yearning for attention and
recognition i think we can
pretty safely assume that caesar
probably didn't exactly have the most
fun childhood as well this is also where
the theme of julius caesar comes into
play
who obviously served as a namesake for
the character and
might hint at some sort of betrayal
happening in his past
and so while it might not compare to the
likes of robin or
brooke i think that caesar's life and
past can definitely be crossed off as
tragic so what about the infamous dream
that every new straw hat needs surely
o'hara isn't proposing that caesar has
a dream and also why is o'hara referring
to himself in the third person
now this speech here that caesar holds
in front of his men
whose demise and suffering he caused
himself
is obviously meant to be pretense
we know that caesar in fact doesn't care
about his men
one bit and that he was the one who
launched a horrendous explosion on the
island
and not vegapunk however i think there
are parts in this speech
that might very well be honest
regardless of whether
caesar is aware of that himself or not
he clearly does want to actually surpass
vegapunk
and wishes for more attention and so i
personally believe that the part where
he talks about his dream to bring peace
to the world through science
might very well be true as well or at
least
was true at some point in time i think
it's not too far-fetched then that
caesar's passion for science didn't
start with the minority complex towards
vegapunk
right from the start but with the
amazement
and joy of experimenting a young boy
with the hopes of making the world a
better place
and losing his path along the way
i think there is quite a strong argument
for this dream to be
the truth
so clearly the argument that caesar
might become a member of the crew
is not completely empty with a quirky
and interesting character
a tragic past and an unfulfilled and
seemingly
unachievable dream caesar certainly
could fit into the ranks of the straw
hats
so what then makes me so certain
that he won't ever join the crew i know
caesar in many ways
is a quite straightforward character
fulfilling the typical trope of the mad
scientist
that doesn't shy away from unethical
methods to satisfy his urge for
discovery
in close connection with his gas devil
food powers
he's a quite toxic and at the same time
elusive character
in many ways he is literally all hot air
relying on trickery and more powerful
people than him for protection
nonetheless his genius is real and
despite his hedonistic lifestyle
he's the only one able to produce the
chemical sad
for doflamingo's artificial devil fruits
and thus
is a priceless asset for both nofi
and kaido for this reason doflamingo
even threatened monet with beth if she
let anything happen to caesar
and made it a priority to retrieve
caesar upon his defeat
[Music]
the true reason why caesar can never be
a straw head however
lies in the rarely mentioned but in my
opinion
most important qualification for any
straw hats
being fundamentally changed by luffy
all of the current straw hats without
one single exception
have been influenced by luffy and have
had a significant
change of heart or turnaround in their
life upon meeting him
luffy literally changed all their lives
to the better
in other words all members of the crew
have a positive character
that ends on a high note when officially
joining the crew
and caesar simply doesn't have that
despite traveling with luffy for so long
his character arc is undeniably
flat
[Music]
as any well-written character he does
have a fundamental lie about the world
that he believes in
that he is a better scientist than
vegapunk
unfairly looked down upon and thus
compelled to beat him at everything he
does
clearly this is not true as is shown
over and over again
vegapunk seems to be the better
scientist
momo's artificial devil fruit was better
than any of the smiles
the numbers are way better than any of
caesar's attempts of gigantification
and there was a reason that he wanted to
get his hands on frankie
and the laser that vagapunk had
developed and yet
despite being confronted with this truth
through his encounters with luffy
he never stops for even a second to
consider that he might use his
intelligence
in other ways to follow his dream that
he's
actually holding himself back with his
obsession with megapunk
oda put him in the exact same spot as
the other straw hats giving him a real
chance to develop but he never does
[Music]
now this is of course not necessarily
bad writing
but a conscious decision of character
design
but in my eyes and i would say probably
also an odas
it fundamentally disqualifies him as a
future straw hat
and so if caesar's purpose is not to
join the crew
what is this
caesar's character serves a number of
important purposes in the story
he goes from a light version of hisoka
whose video by the way will be coming
soon
to buggy over the course of punk hazards
adding a comedic element to the straw
hat's more and more serious journey
into the new worlds
oda sacrifices a lot of his character's
potential
during punk hazard for setting up the
bigger fish during the yonko saga
as a result caesar is introduced as a
supplier for doflamingo
big mom and kaido alike pointing towards
the increasingly intense arcs that will
follow punk hazards
doflamingo in particular steals his show
by arriving on the island in person
threatening to take over the entire arc
if not for aokiji's interference
as a result caesar's role in the story
is reduced to a setup villain that
serves as a measuring stick for the true
threats yet to come
is his character useless then did oda
ruin the potential he had
honestly i would say a bit yeah
caesar could have been way more
interesting as a villain
especially if punk hazard had been a
little bit more condensed
however i think that the real message
behind this character
is something completely different that
often gets lost under
all these other layers
drawing the line all the way back to the
beginning of this video
i believe that caesar despite his
inferiority to vegapunk
is supposed to represent the face of
science and technological advancement
in one piece in a world where pirates
sail on boats
from island to island fighting with
swords and shooting cannons
there suddenly is laser technology and
biochemical weapons of mass destruction
something that seemingly doesn't fit
into the world building at all
and disturbs the adventure-like world
we're exploring
and while oda repeatedly hints that
before the void century
science might have been way more
advanced and possibly even used for the
good
at this point in time it is mainly used
for military purposes
bringing an unfair advantage into
battles that are
otherwise decided through willpower
strength
and the use of mythical devil fruits
caesar as one of the leading scientific
forces
sets off a chemical weapon on punk
hazards killing or crippling most of its
inhabitants
and destroying its environments selling
or creating weapons of mass destruction
for similarly unscrupulous individuals
such as doflamingo
performs sick experiments on children
and drugs them with a lethal
addictive drug to ensure that they do
not run away and
ultimately tries to murder everyone on
punk hazard again
so he could test out his new weapon pad
smiley
all of which he does without so much as
a shred of remorse or empathy
for his potential victims and leading
into the current wano art
he's also responsible for the creation
of the mutative
artificial smile devil fruits that
either
turn the users into grotesque hybrid
creatures
or condemns them to a life unable to
show
any other emotion than laughter
with this i think that oda paints a
quite
dark picture of science through caesar's
character
emphasizing the adventure and freedom
aspect of a more simple and untouched
world
filled with exotic places that have to
be explored by ship
and in addition to that caesar also
leaves us with two
very interesting options for dr vegapunk
who dismissed him as his assistant
due to his unethical behavior that is
one of the
most heatedly discussed issues to this
day
is vagapunk good or bad
given the hints that we've gotten from
oda so far it seems that
vegapunk is secretly helping the
revolutionaries
and even passing some passive aid to the
straw hats
however i think that there is a quite
notable chance
that vegapunk might actually be the true
evil genius of the story
that is way more ruthless and unethical
than caesar
as he's the one responsible for all
those horrendous experimentations in the
first place
that caesar is trying to imitate not
even mentioning the work he conducted
together with judge winsmoke
and so even though he's often not put at
first place by people when it comes to
science and industrial progress in the
story
caesar undoubtedly introduces us to
countless important concepts and
insights about the role that technology
plays in the story
and thus i think that caesar is a quite
unique and important character in the
story that hasn't been used to its full
potential
oda has teased as readers with the quite
real possibility that he might become
the next straw hat
but in the end made it quite clear i
think that you can't join the crew
without correcting the path you walk on
first
ironically enough luffy is able to open
the eyes of caesar's protector
in the next arc that follows
and so if you want to learn the true
meaning of the birdcage for doflamingo
make sure to check out his video here
thanks guys peace